[Music]
June 21st 2019 will see the release of a
brand-new child's play film that reboots
the majority of the Chucky universe as
well as adding a new take on the
character with news emerging weekly on
the film I thought I'd piece together
everything that we know so far about the
film there may be some spoilers here so
if you want to go into the film with
fresh eyes then I highly suggest that
you turn off now for everyone else
welcome to the channel I'm definition
and this is everything we know about the
childsplay reboot the official plot
synopsis for the film is as follows the
story follows a mother named Karen who
gives us an Andy a toy doll for his
birthday unaware of its sinister nature
this of course is very similar to the
original movie even doubted the
character names which are exactly the
same this screenplay was fast-tracked by
MGM and whilst there were several rumors
circulating about the film the majority
of these have turned out to be unfounded
one of the most circulated rumors is
that Chucky would be given a new name
however as of November 16th 2018 MGM
confirmed that the doll's name would
indeed remain the same just opposing
this though branding for the doll would
take a different route with the figure
being promoted as buddy in the majority
of its viral marketing in November 2018
at the official website for the doll was
released which indeed contained the name
buddy on all of the packaging in August
2000 18 bloody digests released an
article stating that the Chucky doll
would in fact be a robot and Andy would
have a group of friends that face off
against it similar to stranger things
more information later surfaced which
stated that the buddy doll was indeed
artificial intelligence and after a
defective design of the robots
programming turned it into a killer this
was apparently caused by a factory
worker that deliberately made the doll
malfunction before killing himself and
of course does away with one of the most
famous aspects of the original Chucky
which is the Voodoo spiritual transforms
us a real killer in other marketing we
see that buddy's features are listed as
state of the art design Wi-Fi
compatibility and voice recognition
basically it sounds like an Alexa with
legs I just hope they can kill it by
turning off the Ruhr the doll learns
from sensory interaction with its
environment and through
cameras in its eyes these eyes allow for
night vision x-ray and a connection to
other body dolls that gives it a full
view of their eye line should one be in
the room the doll is also able to learn
other languages and due to its voice
recognition software I believe that I
will be able to mimic people and thus
pretend to be andis mother or someone
else obviously an AI killer robot is far
more relevant in today's society with
the advancement of technology so this
makes a lot of sense MGM has neither
confirmed or denied this and as their
synopsis is very vague it's difficult to
fully verify it however with all of the
official marketing materials confirming
at least an internet connection is
necessary for the doll it seems very
likely in opposition to this there's
currently a TV show on production by
Universal that will not be tied at the
film's release and stands as its own
entity the reason that MGM are able to
do this is because they made the first
child's play film so they own the rights
to that whereas Universal made the
sequels this will cause conflict as MGM
will not be able to cover any events
from the sequels such as the Bride of
Chucky
however the universal will be able to
recover events from the original movie
as those were recapped in the sequel
films this of course is why the
characters are the same in the remake
however to me it would make a lot more
sense to wildly change and go in a new
direction so what are your thoughts on
the Chucky remake I know a vast amount
of people dislike the fact that it was
going to become a robot but have you
changed your mind after hearing the
in-depth news on it comment below and
let me know and if you enjoyed this
video then please like it and check out
my breakdown of this week's big horror
movie the possession of Hannah grace
this is a channel for people who are
heavy into horror so if that's the kind
of thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]